Recently, more than a couple of knitters
contacted me to tell me they just
couldn't get their gauge right.
One had knit a sleeve
and it was way too long.
The other one had knit an entire
sweater and it was way too big.
No, there isn't anything
wrong with the pattern.
It's just math.
Let's go back to the swatch
and see where they're struggling.
I often ask knitters to take
a photo of their swatch with rulers.
In a it doesn't matter if you use
machine netter scale or a regular ruler.
Often having another set of eyes to look
at your swatch reveals the problem.
This knitter insisted
that her gauge was 18.5 stitches to 4 inches.
Now take a look and can you see that she
had positioned her ruler scale
along the edge of the knitting?
The yellow ruler is designed
to measure over 30 stitches.
Back to the drawing board,
she measured between 30 stitches
and got an accurate gauge.
In this example, can you see the problem?
Using the stitch scale to measure
rows will cause all sorts of problems.
Some time ago, a dear friend was sad
because she had run out
of yarn for her project.
She couldn't get any more of it.
She showed me her swatch,
and I was She was amazed.
She told me the ball band said
that the gauge was three stitches per inch,
so she cast on three stitches
and it measured one inch.
What was wrong with that?
Obviously, she needed
to knit a larger swatch.
This last example has
a whole bunch of problems.
First, it isn't big enough.
We need to knit a swatch that is large
enough to measure a four-inch
square in the middle.
We can measure gauge more accurately
without those curled
edges impacting things.
Next, it looks like the knitter wants
to use the yellow scale,
but she needs 30 stitches in the middle
of her knitting to use the scale.
She didn't make a large enough swatch.
Third, she marked some stitches with pins.
But why take time to count
stitches and do all that math?
Mark them as you knit
and there's no counting.
Next, the curled edges are going to make
it much more difficult
to measure accurately.
Dress your swatch, wash,
and block it as you're going to treat your
project so that you
can accurately measure.
It makes a big difference.
Lastly, this bind-off
edge is way too tight.
It's distorting the edge,
and the edge is making it impossible
to measure the gauge accurately.
I don't like to use the word worthless,
but in this case,
this knitter needs to start all over
and knit a proper swatch that's large
enough to mark stitches and rows
according to the scale she'll use.
She needs to bind off loosely
and dress her swatch.
She'll have much more success
with gauge in her knitting.